- Ви з Лисичанська?
- Так.
- Як там було?
- Пекло!
Французька журналістка, яка працює на лінії фронту,
зустріла українських військових, що відступили з Лисичанська.
- Це вони вже зараз там заходять, так?
- Яка ваша перша реакція?
- Які відчуття? Негативні, звісно.
- Сумно?
- Так, звісно…
- Злість?
Українським солдатам боляче бачити, що тепер над госпіталем у Лисичанську майорить червоний прапор
зразка 1945 року як знак того, що місто тепер під контролем Росії.
Тим небагатьом мешканцям, хто залишився у вакуумі російської окупації,
роздають георгіївські стрічки та сухі пайки.
- Манна каша та макарони…
- Синок, а водички немає у вас?
Більшість мешканців на межі морального та фізичного виснаження від нескінченних обстрілів,
вибухів та необхідності ховати своїх сусідів прямо у дворі.
Це зовсім свіжа могила - чоловік вийшов із дому по воду….
…і не дійшов. Осколок потрапив у нього на цьому самому місці.
Він не заслуговував на те, щоб загинути отак.
Влада так званої Луганської народної республіки подає взяття Лисичанська як остаточну перемогу Росії
на Луганщині. Тим часом президент Зеленський пообіцяв, що місто обов'язково повернуть під контроль Києва.
Ми бережемо життя наших вояків, наших людей.
Стіни ми відбудуємо, землю відвоюємо, а людей треба берегти понад усе.
І якщо командування нашої армії і забирає людей із певних точок фронту,
де ворог має найбільшу вогневу перевагу, – зокрема це стосується й Лисичанська, – це означає тільки одне:
що ми повернемося завдяки нашій тактиці, завдяки нарощуванню постачання сучасного озброєння.
Україна нічого не віддає.
Захоплення Лисичанська є найбільшим успіхом армії РФ з моменту захоплення Маріуполя у травні.
І все ж, на думку західних експертів, це не можна розцінювати як поразку українського війська,
радше як успішну операцію відступу.
Лисичанськ сам по собі не є якоюсь нищівною поразкою.
Це зміна української лінії фронту.
Схоже, звичайні регулярні українські війська, які змогли скоординуватися і вийти звідти,
зробили це саме вчасно, перш ніж котел було повністю закрито.
Але це, безумовно, зробили, поставши перед досить суворим вибором:
залишитися там і піти на таку ж долю, як у Сєвєродонецька чи Маріуполя, або ж
відступити і спробувати продовжити битву пізніше.
Гадаю, ми маємо розглядати це у контексті.
Так, це успіх для пропаганди Путіна - повернення Луганської області, як він це називає,
тоді як українці справедливо називають це вторгненням, взяттям.
Але те, що ми спостерігали останні кілька місяців - це досконала оборона українців з огляду
на баланс між поступками на землі і завданням втрат росіянам.
І те, що ми бачили в останні кілька днів, - це як блискуче було виконано бойовий відступ українців,
щоб допомогти вирівняти лінію фронту.
Отже, якщо розглядати це в контексті, слід пам'ятати, що росіяни намагалися зробити це
протягом аж двох з половиною місяців і зазнали тисячних втрат у цих спробах.
На думку західних військових аналітиків, наступними цілями російського наступу після Лисичанська
можуть стати Слов'янськ, Бахмут і Сіверськ.
Як написало міністерство оборони Великобританії в Twitter з посиланням на дані своєї розвідки,
попереду - битва за Донецьку область, яка швидше за все буде схожа на події в Луганській.
Зокрема, за висновком британського міноборони, бої на Луганщині характеризувалися
повільними темпами наступу, масовими ударами російської артилерії,
в ході яких - цитата - міста зрівнювали із землею.
Утім, у спецслужбі зазначають, що тепер українським силам буде легше тримати оборону
завдяки вирівнюванню лінії фронту.
Для українців це означає, що лінія фронту змінила форму.
Раніше вони були ніби оточені російськими військами або принаймні заблоковані з трьох боків,
що створювало багато проблем для українського війська.
А зараз лінія фронту певною мірою укріплена.
Тож зараз головне завдання українців полягає в тому,
щоб утримати цю лінію фронту і не допустити подальшого відступу,
щоб вони змогли почати сповільнювати просування Росії, а потім, сподіваюся, й самим перейти в наступ.
Західні військові експерти кажуть, що битва за Донецьку область може стати поворотним пунктом у війні
- не через стратегічну цінність зруйнованих міст,
а через вплив людських та збройних втрат на здатність обох сторін продовжувати боротьбу.
Сподівання України на контратаку великою мірою залежить від постачання зброї Заходом.
Зокрема на артилерію, яка може нейтралізувати величезну вогневу перевагу Росії.
Якщо українці отримають те, що їм потрібно, вони доволі швидко зможуть закінчити цю війну
проти старої та погано навченої, досить виснаженої російської армії.
Але вони не отримують того, що їм потрібно.
Ця крапельна подача зброї, яку ми нині спостерігаємо, має перетворитися на потік.
Я підозрюю, що в найближчі кілька місяців українська армія спробує відвоювати якусь територію на півдні.
Але вони не можуть бути впевнені в успіху, поки Захід не зробить реальних кроків.
Як на мене, війна триватиме надто довго, якщо українці не отримають того, що їм потрібно.
Вони триматимуться, боронитимуть свою землю  і зрештою досягнуть успіху.
Але питання у тому, як довго ми на Заході хочемо покладати на них цю війну?
А поки що українським солдатам нерідко доводиться воювати з такою зброєю в руках…
- Рік 1944…
- І ви використовуєте її?
- Так, звісно.